so the president of El Salvador naib
buelli appears to have just won
reelection by the single largest margin
in modern democratic history the
official results are not final yet but
he reportedly captured nearly 90% of the
vote which is a massive jump from five
years ago when he received just a little
over 50% now outside of North Korea you
don't see numbers like this very often
they sound way too high to be real but
in El Salvador they're not that
surprising all the polls predicted
precisely this outcome there were
massive parties in the streets
celebrating B re-election before it even
happened so when buelli was named the
winner everybody saw it coming it made
sense there were no Angry mobs storming
Parliament alleging fraud or putting
their feet up on some politician's desk
instead this weekend here's what El
Salvador looked
[Applause]
[Music]
like
[Applause]
previously I've gone into some detail
about why naib melli is so popular but I
can restate it here very quickly because
it's not that complicated Buell is
historically popular and was just
reelected by a vast margin because he
puts his own country first he protects
his own people he looks out for their
security and their well-being and uh he
makes his community safer and more
livable that's it it's that simple
that's that's the whole equation and any
politician who does that is going to be
very popular when belly took office
gangs controlled roughly 80% of the
country and these gangs had killed more
than 100,000 citizens over the past
three decades making El Salvador one of
the most dangerous countries on the
planet but shortly after he took office
buelli started rounding up everybody
affiliated with these criminal gangs who
usually are not that hard to spot
because they have tattoos on their face
announcing what gang they're with now
this has infuriated civil liberties
groups but it worked homicides in El
Salvador are down
92% compared to 2015 90% of the country
now views buelli favorably as a result
and again it's not hard to see why they
can go out at night without getting shot
they can operate business without
getting extorted their families are much
safer pretty simple of course that won't
stop civil liberties groups from
complaining claiming that some people in
El Salvador are now falsely accused of
gang involvement uh they want us to
believe that El Salvador's government
should should air on the side of
protecting civil liberties at all costs
rather than on the side of you know
preserving the safety and well-being of
their communities it's better for 100
guilty people to go free than for one
innocent person to go to prison as the
common refrain goes the problem with
that argu arent which is now obvious to
everybody in El Salvador is that you
cannot enjoy civil liberties when
there's a total breakdown of Law and
Order you don't have any constitutional
rights whatsoever when you're dead the
Civil Libertarians had their chance in
El Salvador and they failed to safeguard
civil liberties and it all it all broke
down it failed history is very clear on
this in 2012 El Salvador's president at
the time broker a truce with the
country's most powerful gangs MS13 and
the 18th Street gang the idea was that
showing lean iy might lower the murder
rate to that to that end many gang
leaders were transferred from maximum
security prisons to low security prisons
gangs also had free reign to expand
their territory and communicate with
their leaders in prison what was the
result of that well within two years the
truce broke down the violence resumed
and El Salvador became one of the most
dangerous countries in the world
averaging 105 homicides per 100,000
people which is a lot let's just put it
that way El Salvador learned from that
mistake in fact El Salvador's government
went on to pursue criminal charges
against the former president who
brokered that
truce and there's not a single
reasonable person in El Salvador who
believes in this kind of compromise
anymore because they know where it leads
the country is now overwhelmingly in
favor of enforcing the rule of law
without regard for the concerns of
humanitarians or civil liberties
organizations whether you think that's a
good outcome or not and again almost
everybody in El Salvador thinks that
it's good really doesn't matter what
happened in El Salvador will happen
eventually in any country that
disregards its duty to protect its
citizens at a certain point people can't
take it anymore they restore order one
way or another when you're not when you
don't feel safe to walk outside of your
house you could only endure that for so
long I wanted to begin with El Salvador
because the situation there is such an
obvious and important contrast with what
just happened in Washington DC this
weekend unlike the leaders of El
Salvador politicians in this country are
still committed to the uh some sort of
platonic ideal of compromise rather than
upholding their constitutional duty to
protect this country and the American
citizens who live here to that end even
as hundreds of thousands of illegal
aliens stream across the border every
month including criminals from places
like El Salvador looking for you know a
friendlier place to commit crimes a
bipartisan group of US senators just
agreed on a border deal that would do
absolutely nothing to secure the
southern border I'm going to elaborate
on what this bill would do because it's
such an unbelievable betrayal that it's
actually hard to believe that it's real
but before I do that it's important to
emphasize that no border bill or
compromise is necessary at all under
existing laws including the immigration
nationality Act of 1952 the president of
the United States can turn every single
illegal alien away at the border if he
determines that it's necessary to safu
uh the country there is no requirement
that we entertain fraudulent Asylum
claims or even legitimate Asylum claims
as rare as those may be there is no
requirement that we allow a single
non-citizen into this country period all
that's necessary to secure the border is
for the president of the United States
to start enforcing the law to start
using the power that he already has
legitimately and
constitutionally it doesn't need to be
complicated we don't even need an L
Salvador style Crackdown to accomplish
this we just need to enforce existing
laws as they
stand but if the White House actually
adopted a simple straightforward
solution to the Border crisis then two
things would happen one the Democratic
party would lose out on hundreds of
thousands of future loyal voters because
their long-standing plans for
demographic replacement would be styed
in that case and two Congress would miss
out on a great chance to launder
millions of dollars and Congress never
misses out on any opportunity like that
so here we are and here are the details
the Border proposal that the Senate is
advancing would allocate another $60
billion in military aid to Ukraine it
would send 14 billion in military aid to
Israel that's a grand total of $74
billion that's going to other countries
by comparison the bill would allocate
$20 billion for border
security so to restate in case you're
keeping track at home our leaders just
agreed to a plan that would spend
roughly 400% more tax money on foreign
countries than on securing our own
country and it gets worse because even
the money that's supposedly going to be
used at the border supposedly to secure
our country will actually just
facilitate the illegal entry of millions
of illegal aliens into this country
specifically the legislation would
provide another $2.3 billion to quote
Refugee and entrant assistance
activities including quote grants or
contracts with qualified organizations
including nonprofit entities to provide
culturally and linguistically
appropriate services including housing
assistance medical assistance legal
assistance and ease management M
assistance so that's more than $2
billion to support the leftwing
nonprofits that exist simply to find
creative ways to sneak as many illegal
immigrants into this country as possible
we're even throwing in free legal servic
services for illegals uh just just to
sweeten the pot for them this bill is
actually creating more incentives for
illegals to come here in the first place
you may have seen reporting that the the
bill states that the executive branch
must close the border on eer basis if
quote during a period of seven
consecutive calendar days there is an
average of 5,000 or more aliens who are
encountered each day or if quote on any
one calendar day combined total of 8,500
or more aliens are encountered that's
how various Outlets including NBC News
have reported on this bill it's also how
Oklahoma senator James lenford who's
supposedly a republican has pitched this
legislation they all say that once 5,000
people come in every day for a week then
the border is shut down uh and here's
what lford wrote last night quote the
emergency Authority is not designed to
let 5,000 people in it is designed to
close the border and turn 5,000 people
around but that's just simply not true
for three reasons first of all the bill
gives Joe Biden the authority to wave
this border emergency Authority at any
time he can simply ignore the bill
effectively and so can DHS secretary
Alejandro mayorcas so I mean that alone
means that it doesn't it it it doesn't
mean anything it doesn't do anything
because writing into the legislation
that oh by the way Biden you could just
ignore this and so he
will secondly the bill doesn't even
account doesn't even count unaccompanied
miners from countries other than Canada
or Mexico in the number of Encounters in
other words many illegal migrants from
Guatemala Haiti El Salvador India
Honduras the Philippines China Etc just
flat out don't count towards the 5,000
total like we could have 20,000 of those
show up and it it wouldn't count they
are IL Al migrants but they're not
relevant to this part of the bill for
whatever reason and then on top of all
that the bill doesn't actually close the
border even if this fraudulent 5,000
migrant threshold is reached this is a
direct quote from Senator Chris Murphy
one of the authors of the bill for this
is what he said last night quote the
bill contains a requirement that the
president funnel Asylum claims to the
land ports of Entry when more than 5,000
people cross a day the Border never
closes but claims must be processed at
the ports
so maybe you catch the contradiction
there Chris Murphy one of the bills
authors says the Border never closes at
the same time James Langford another of
the Bill's authors says quote it is
designed to close the border so two
authors of the bill one is saying it
closes the border the other one says it
doesn't so our leaders are either Liars
or they're bumbling idiots who can't
keep their story straight or both
probably both really but if you read the
bill the implications of the text are
pretty obvious it says that once we hit
5,000 illegals per day we we don't
actually close the border instead we
direct them to Ports of Entry where they
can make their Asylum claims and then
enter the country from there so this is
a complete scam essentially and it's
intended to be a scam that runs for a
very long time time the bill has a
sunset provision three years into the
future the idea is to bind a future
Trump Administration to the terms of
this
deal now you might say wait a minute
let's say that 5,000 person threshold is
reached and then these migrants have to
report to a port of entry and make an
asylum claim surely you might think well
we wouldn't simply allow all of these
migrants into the country right because
that would be
insane but if you thought that you would
be wrong in one key respect this border
compromise would actually lessen the
already minimal standards for allowing
Asylum applicants into this country
because right now migrants who arrive at
a Port of Entry uh supposedly need to
show a significant possibility quote
unquote that they can establish quote
credible fear of persecution on the
basis of race national origin uh
political beliefs Etc now that's what it
requires to be to get Asylum not a very
high standard like it doesn't require
migrants to present any evidence for
anything they say they can just make a
claim which they've rehearsed and then
get into the country that's the status
quo but this border bill would lower
that standard even further somehow from
requiring a significant possibility of
persecution to a reasonable possibility
of pers
persecution so from significant to
reasonable and reasonable is just
another way of saying plausible it's
like it's it's possible plausibly
possible that I can be
persecuted in other words it's a it's a
it's a a bar that any s anyone from any
country can get
over so in practice we can assume
there's basically no way that anyone
claiming Asylum will ever get turned
away if that's the standard
and then once these fake Asylum
applicants are here this bill will
shower them with new benefits including
guaranteed work permits and free
lawyers and there are other giveaways in
there as well for example family units
and unaccompanied miners will be
released into the country when they're
caught like they're not going to be
detained they're just going to be
released right away and I could go on
but suffice to say this proposed bill is
just an
Abomination it's not simply inadequate
or ineffective at securing the Border it
makes the Border even less secure than
it already is which is a remarkable feat
that few if any people imagine was even
possible fortunately it does appear as
of today that the house will not
consider this Senate Bill the speaker
Mike Johnson and Majority Leader Steve
scales have said that it's Dead on
Arrival they're not going to even do a
vote on it which is good news it doesn't
begin though to explain why Senate
Republicans thought this bill was
reasonable in the first place and it
doesn't get us any closer to securing
the southern B border which is a which
is a
necessity we are in this position for
one reason which is that we have
assembled a government composed almost
entirely of anti buelles we might call
them people who despise their own
citizens and whose top priority is the
Safety and Security of countries
thousands of miles from their own
Shores and they know it because when you
point out their complete their election
of Duty they don't even defend their
record they don't offer any explanation
for how they're keeping illegal
immigrants out of the country instead
they call you a racist say you're a bad
person for asking them questions in fact
that's what happened just a few months
ago at a hearing in the Senate watch as
the DHS secretary Alejandro mayorcas
responds to questioning from Josh Holly
about the Border crisis and listen to
what he
says Mr secretary I think that your
performance is Despicable and I think
the fact that you are not willing to
provide answers to this committee is
absolutely
atrocious Mr chairman may I like if
you'd like to have a minute to respond
you were I would and I'm not sure I'll
limit it to 60 seconds that's fine
number one uh what I found despicable is
the
implication uh that uh this language
tremendously odious um uh actually could
be emblematic of the sentiments of the
260,000 men and women of the Department
of Homeland Security number one number
two uh Senator Holly takes a adversarial
approach to me in this question and
perhaps he doesn't know my own
background perhaps he does not know that
I am the child of a holocaust
Survivor perhaps he does not know that
my mother lost almost all her
family at the hands of the Nazis and so
I find his adversarial tone to be
entirely
misplaced I find it to be disrespectful
of me and my heritage
and I do not expect an apology but I did
want to say what I just articulated
thank you Mr chairman can can I just
respond since he has referenced me
personally Senator H we need to move on
Senator
Romney oh Senator you want to know why
I'm not doing my job but do you realize
that my mother was in the
Holocaust what what what does that have
to do with anything like what relevance
does that have this is a guy who under
this new border bill has total
discretion over whether to turn people
away at the border or not and my orcus
justifies his failures On the Border by
commenting that his mother is a
holocaust Survivor it makes no sense it
has no relevance to anything but it does
show you how little respect these people
have for our
intelligence that they think we'll hear
that and say well okay well never mind
we can't crit his mother was in the
Holocaust so we can't criticize him for
what he's doing on the border all right
I'll buy that he expects us to to say
and it's not just the Biden
Administration that thinks like this
Republicans in the Senate just agreed to
this bill and keep in mind Democrats are
getting decimated in the polls most
Americans do not support this this
Administration there is no political
calculation that justifies any
Republican Party Support for this
proposal but Republicans in the Senate
backed it anyway whatever the reason for
that maybe they wanted to reward their
donors or interest groups or maybe
they're completely incompetent uh or
maybe again both it's a relevant these
people simply cannot lead us any longer
nobody is buying the idea that we need a
lengthy multi-billion dollar giveaway to
Ukraine and Israel in order to enforce
the law and defend this country from
Invasion and most Americans want our
leaders to prioritize our country before
any other country that is not an
unreasonable thing for us to
want nobody seriously thinks that it's
appropriate to pay foreign countries
vast sums of money to secure their
borders while we all a fraction of that
money to open up our borders even more
it's just it's too much these people
have looted the treasury for too long
because of what they've done America is
careening at high speed toward its own
Al Salvador
moment and at this point it can't get
here fast enough hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there